And here's the finished product.
I'll open up devtools and take a look.
Inside the style tag,
you can see that I just simply did
exactly what you learned a minute ago.
Only this time, I'm dividing by three,
instead of two.
To break this down,
I set a margin rate of ten pixels, so
that each image has a margin to
the right of it of ten pixels.
And I set the last-of-type selector
on the image to margin-right 0.
This make sure that there's
no margin after the last one.
Then to calculate the width I simply
took the whole viewport, 100%,
subtracted the 20 pixels taken up by
the two margins, and divided it by 3.
Calc is really awesome.
I hope you realize just
how awesome this is.
You're mixing and matching units and
it's giving you something useful.
Make sure you take advantage
of calc whenever you can.